thank you and segue to what I was
getting into Laura Loomer that's right
Laura Loomer we're getting into all the
new stuff here in a second but we like
to do stuff first hasn't seen this yet
because it was supposed to why he was
driving over here
it's bad it's bad oh Virgie Fergie
Fergie it's bad Laura Loomer tweeted out
are you ready you know how you know how
like so excited you know how like a lot
of people have coffee brands now right
yeah we all enjoy a nice cup of coffee
every once in a while what's something
you're kind of a health nut what's
something if you don't want to put sugar
in your coffee oh you could use uh monk
fruit
forgiving
Splendor oh that's I was gonna say isn't
it like an artificial snow Yeah monk
fruits are real it's a good sweetener
it's actually made out of real fruit and
has a very low sugar there's a fun fact
for you keto heads out there I call them
keto heads now okay he's purposely like
filibustering when there's we clearly
know at the end I know but but I I
really I really want you know I know
what you're gonna say but I want to
stress this I want to stretch this
stretch this out I'll tell you why
because I don't want what we're about to
read to end and I'm afraid if I started
it's gonna end at some point I have to
end this paragraph and I don't want to
it's like it's like a Tony it's like a
Tony con hog during when he grabs a
wrestler and hugs him yeah I don't want
this to ever end
stroke come to coke with me in the back
he whispers in his ear
um he's talking to Sean rossapp
yes
take a hair test for it I offered to pay
for Sean Ross Sapp's hair test and he
won't respond he's taking a piss test
everybody knows cocaine's a drug you do
if you're getting tested because
depending on what your metabolism is
it'll be out in one day to three days at
the longest if you have a shitty
metabolism I was on probation for seven
months do you know how many times I did
cocaine in that seven months
[Laughter]
look man they never they never test you
on Fridays because they don't want to
work either so you just [__] Friday
Saturday Sunday by Monday you're like
cam me a cup ready to go uh Laura Loomer
excited to announce I I can't imagine it
you want me to try it yes go ahead you
try you do it
excited to announce I have partnered
with Ultra Mega honey
make honey great again
when did when when was it honey grape
Honey's just honey bro Honey's been
around honey has been a food staple for
thousands of years before before even
before even bread yeah we had honey
first don't give me none of that liberal
honey
they probably put the backs in it it's
trans bees making the liberal honey
it gets better you have no idea because
you haven't seen it yet bees only got
two genders
and only one [__] in the entire Hive
that's kind of gay can I I I'm I'm this
is please no go ahead make Connie great
again is pure raw honey so is literally
any honey label that's Raw Pure honey
I love looking at this honey now there
is no physical way this is raw pirani so
please read the next line when you
purchase honey from Ultra Magnus oh God
yeah oh no no yes
let's read it read it the bottles
are are shaped like Donald Trump's face
yeah they are
merch look up Mercy look
you want to live more yeah I hope that
[__] is pure poison
I hope that a month from now some
redditor just decides I'm Gonna Fill one
of these with come
yeah sure redditer I'm buying some now
um uh so they're shaped like Billy is
gonna use it like a Fleshlight
when you purchase honey from Ultra Mega
honey and use the code lumer a checkout
a percentage of the sales will go
towards supporting my Pro Maga activism
there you go and don't even get a
discount and no no I like that she
totally just gave up on journalist and
now she's like I'm a Maga activist like
okay yeah
uh Mega activism in the field reporting
that so many of you enjoy you can get
your Maga honey here please use code
Luma at checkout thank you make Honey
great again.com so they gotta pay Trump
to use his likeness right
so he's getting a taste of this right
yeah I'm checking out the site twenty
dollars twenty dollars for honey for
honey it's a 16 ounce bottle of dog [__]
hey Royce you wanna
oh God I'm so excited go to go to go to
shop right quick go to the shop okay
Shopkins yeah go shop
what does that say underneath the bottle
for wholesale pricing please call
1-844-45 honey
should we call and ask about wholesale
pricing for honey
we should probably probably be calling
us all right we could call but one of us
has to take points but actually we could
both out we could say that we're from a
distributor yeah yeah we're from what
distributor we have to let's think this
one now what distributor would it be it
has to be uh uh public oh God Publix no
but Publix isn't a distributor yeah
Cisco Cisco
Cisco's a distributor
no no no no no no no no no no I want
something that they'll Google and go oh
oh
my God somebody in the chat says merch
call us Trump do the Trump voice
it's the best honey great honey sweet
honey
I don't know who gave you the rights to
my life oh that would be really funny
like you did Sir you'll be a faster
lawsuit than [__] ice him
um which by the way which that's another
thing that's been hilarious
um have you read the lawsuit yeah I've
read the law so [__] yeah he's done
all right I have one New Vista Foods
Group Tampa Florida
okay you could take Point more she you
got this you are okay yeah you got it
you got it
this is Todd how may I assist you
hello good afternoon yes I'm sorry about
that um I'm having some bad connection
issues here how you doing
I'm good my name is Jeremy Simon uh yeah
I'm actually uh well no we're actually
out here in Tampa my name is Jeremy
Simon I'm with the New Vista Foods Group
and uh we were interested uh in
potentially maybe Distributing your
product you have the uh is this the make
honey great again.com
it is it is thank god well you know how
we are out here in Florida man and we're
just we're just sick of all that you
know pro-trans lib libtard pro-vax honey
it makes me sick to my stomach and just
can't good conscience distribute
products like that we were just
wondering if you had like uh some
information you'd be able to send us
well sure so so what do you what do you
guys do then tell me uh
we sell honey you say when you
distribute by the boatload we sell honey
by the boat yeah we we got uh bees
everywhere it's actually frankly
becoming a concern we've had uh several
write-ups from the city and they've told
us stop with the bees you gotta stop
there's other businesses this is a
commercial park you know what I mean and
they're always going back and forth and
I'm going with them and they're suing me
it's it's it's insane but you know how
it is it's all politically motivated
wow do you know you know a woman by the
name of Laura Loomer I do actually I'm
very familiar with her work she's uh
latch did great stuff during the Vegas
shooting and uh yeah she's a great
supporter of President Trump
yeah see I just I I was on the phone
with her a couple times today she's a
client of mine so that must have been
exhausting huh
what's that
so that must have been exactly well yeah
you said you're on the phone a couple
times today she can be a little wired oh
sometimes she's very ex you know her
passion you know it's you know sometimes
it's a good thing sometimes you know oh
it's huge oh yeah yeah yeah
I talked to her before and then I was
invited uh two weeks ago to go to
Springfield Missouri for Mike Lindell
and we raised money from Mike Lindell at
his election Mike Lindell fantastic
supporter of mine great guy terrific guy
sells pillows on the television it's
terrible what happened to Mike what
they've done to that poor guy can't even
advertise on Fox News
do you know that he's um he has spent 60
million dollars in his election stuff
you know these lawsuits he's been sued
against and he told us he had to borrow
another five million and then he
borrowed a million dollars to do this
event last week or two weeks ago it was
a private invitation uh event for he he
has the plan that he unveiled to
everybody I can't he's too nice
that was sorry I was I was
he's I can't man I'm getting too old for
this [__] bro
oh no now he's gonna oh God now we're
getting now and now we're gonna hear the
end of it no I just block him
[Laughter]
dude I'm getting too old for it back in
the day I would have broke that man's
[__] heart like you know what I gotta
tell you I muted myself because I don't
want to laugh it on the mic but
I will say this merch has really grown
as a person I feel bad because merch
used to go for the [__] remember the guy
with the Vampire book during the fifth
that's one of my favorite things we've
ever done about that guy's [__] I
bought that on locals for you guys today
that guy was rough I called [__] uh
Narcissa right and for like 10 minutes
tried to braid her into killing herself
those are the good old days
um I yeah I I mean I he was just being
nice and then I was like ah this guy
like I feel bad man like I know he's a
grifter he's selling [__] Trump honey
but I hate a cycle bad guy
it was just I was like that's why I
started waving a voice
when you did the Trump voice that guy
that's what broke me I'll be honest with
you
oh [__] man yeah that poor guy though I
can kind of like yeah yeah it's uh I I
just man I I don't have it in me anymore
man he's everywhere
he's everywhere
I feel like uh I feel like Cuddy from
The Wire when he finally just gives up
on the game and he just comes in he's
like man whatever that is you got in you
that he makes you the way you is I just
don't have it no more
Esteban says merch should be on Saturday
Night Live oh yeah me and Shane Gillis
uh apathy you're way more racist than he
is and they didn't let him on apathetic
Crow honey is what merch calls loomers
loomers over the phone that's what
that's why she got the idea
he sounded like a man being taken
advantage of by Laura Loomer he said
yeah probably that's every sexual
relationship she's had a man being taken
advantage of by Laura Loomer how long
before we get a tweet from Laura Loomer
they're already calling and harassing
our great Maga ultimate mega sponsor
no we were I was having fun with him but
then I was like okay I need to bail
which is why I started doing Trump
because I said there's two ways out of
this I start doing a try again
or I or I do something that we're all
gonna feel bad about it no you did the
right thing you know
what I mean you're excited about Mike
it's like meeting the meeting the ball
guy and him being like wow you're really
going to distribute my product you're
like oh man because this guy's selling
[__] honey and re retrofitted Aunt
Jemima bottles look like Trump and he's
[__] like granted like this guy's
gonna be ruined in a year you know what
I mean like he's literally this guy is
gonna be going I'm ruined I put all my
money in the Trump honey [__] and all
you hear behind him while he's crying
and he can't pay his bills is
[Music]
that lorealuma counting money that is
Laura Luma County money with a machine
Oh I thought I'm sure you thought it was
B's um Forest mommy with twenty dollars
Legend thank you for us Mommy uh lean
and mean we got bees everywhere that's
the joke that's the one that broke me
thank you Marsh very funny
Bravo boys Jay Weezy thank you so much
forever two wheels 070707 gentlemen
thanks for the laughs I should have
known then that something was wrong
right because it's like so I have why
because someone was interested in his
product that too but I mean if I'm
surrounded by bees the [__] do I need
you for yeah I'm lousy with B it's just
like you you're the last thing I need is
a [__] honey a source of Honey now I
would have gotten this just of course my
move would have been like look I'm not
gonna lie to you I'm a little underwater
I got these bees on discount turns out
they're [__] Hornets they're awesome
so all I have is a bunch of hornets I
spent thirty thousand dollars on
Malaysian wasps yeah that's awesome and
it turns out we don't have that breed of
wasp here in Florida and it's an
invasive species really so I'm also
facing federal charges
[Laughter]
they've killed they've killed so many
egrets and they're endangered so we're
really [__] right now I watched one of
these little sons of [__] snatch up a
baby alligator earlier just fly off with
them these things are dangerous
all right God that was so much fun
triple n yeah it didn't make sense but
he was blinded by honey
so stupid
Oh [__]
um leaning mean operation waspy
thank you lean